[Musik]
hallöchen ihr süßen heute gibt es eine
lasagne suppe die habe ich letztes jahr
zum fastenbrechen gemacht da muss es
schnell gehen und trotzdem lecker
schmecken da habe ich so instagram
gezeigt und ihr habt gesagt dass uns
entweder sanya suppe und jetzt zeigt
dieses mega lecker und jetzt wo du
gerade spricht kaum seit heute
geburtstag zeigt er doch alle ungewohnt
sagte rein in die kommentare heute ist
der neunte mehr
naja das ist gar nicht peinlich und
anlässlich des geburtstags habe ich auch
eine rote paprika mit reingenommen
interesse gerne gerne das ist doch ganz
ehrlich das dass das wahre geschenk das
man im schenkens und nicht in welche
materiellen güter so ganz genau
jetzt fand nicht an die zwiebeln zu
schnippeln ich schreibe euch wie immer
alle ganz genauen mengenangaben hier
unten in die video beschreibung und ja
ich stimme dir jetzt einfach dann kommt
noch ein bisschen ein paar märchen
schnitzel ich noch und eben auch die
paprika und dieses schöne muster bekommt
ihr mit dem wellen schneider hin
verlinkt ich mich auch unten in die
infobox und ich finde er sich schon
direkt appetitlicher aus wir gehen jetzt
aber einmal rüber zum mitklatschen
wir gehen jetzt einmal wird zum herbst
deswegen erwarte ich bis die kamera
gleichauf pause ist und ich habe mich
schon mal olivenöl in einem topf dann
nimmt er am besten in beschichteten topf
und da gebe ich jetzt ganz einfach so
ein bisschen hack verschreien und
brothers krümelig
[Musik]
nach ungefähr zwei zweieinhalb minuten
geben wir dann salz und verfassung
hackfleisch und außerdem werden dann
direkt zwiebeln und knoblauch mit
angedünstet dann könnte auch von der
stufe herrn bisschen niedriger gehen und
jetzt gebe ich gestückelte tomaten aus
der dose mit dazu und ein bisschen
gemüsebrühe und anschließend kann auch
schon das ganze gemüse da rein und ihr
könnt auch anderes gemüse den wenn die
meisten gibt meist rein oder oder oder
da gibt's das sind möglichkeiten und ich
hab doch noch meister zugegeben hat sich
jetzt auch noch da also ist es jetzt
richtig schön bunt und da kommt jetzt
die gewürze dazu ich nehme gerne paprika
edelsüß dann nämlich einmal noch die
scharfe paprika variante natürlich
oregano mit tomate passt es perfekt mit
tomate was auch immer eine prise zucker
die füge ich gleich noch hinzu und die
habe ich kreuzkümmel das finde ich passt
super zum hackfleisch
[Musik]
so dass ganze küche geht schon vor sich
hin und jetzt fehlen nur noch lasagne
blätter die dürfen dann mit köchen so
lange bis sie gar sind und es gibt jetzt
nicht so als ganzes rein kommt man dann
später eben besser essen kann und
schmücken kann einfach so ein bisschen
ja kaputt machen und direkt mit
reingehen und ich denke die brauchen so
ungefähr 15 bis maximal 20 minuten und
dann ist die komplette suppe auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
noch ein tipp von mir was super passt
und lorbeerblätter die gebe ich jetzt
noch mit rein dürfen nicht vergessen die
nachher wieder rauszunehmen so und jetzt
den deckel drauf und köcheln lassen
also wir essen die lasagne suppe am
allerliebsten mit sondern richtig fetten
klecks creme fraiche das schmeckt so gut
und ein bisschen geriebenen gouda
obendrauf den schmelz ist nochmals in
der rest hitze richtig lecker krieg
schon so in wässrigen mund beim rc daher
lasst uns das jetzt schmecken und
genießen noch handels geburtstag das mit
abend ausklingen euch ganz viel freude
beim nachkochen und schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare welches herzhafter
rezepte als nächstes sehen möchtet und
dann sehen wir uns mit diesem rezept
video teure kiki
[Musik]